MARKUS KLUTE: All right,
so welcome back to 8.801.
We'll continue our discussion
on Feynman calculus.
And here we dive
into toy theory.
So this theory is a toy.
And it's just an example to
illustrate Feynman rules.
What we do, the
simplification we employ here
is leaving out the spin
of the particle involved.
We consider the spin, we add
another algebraic complication
which is quite now confusing.
So we leave this out for now.
We come back later to this.
So we're supposed to have three
kinds of particles involved
here-- particle A,
B, and C. And so we
can have a primary vertex where
these all three particle are
interacting like shown here.
So particle A, might decay
into particle B and C.
You can assume that
particle A is heavier
than the sum of B and C, so
this is schematically allowed.
We might also have corrections
involved here as shown here.
And what we'd be interested
in is now, for example,
calculating the lifetime
of this particle A.
We might do this just for
this primitive vertex.
Or we might do this for this
complicated set of corrections.
We might also be interested
in calculating scattering
processes where particle A
is scattered with particle A
and produces particle
B and particle B.
Or we scatter particle A
with particle B and so on.
So in this theory, at
the end of the lecture,
we have all tools in
hand to calculate this.
No worries-- I will not
leave you alone with this.
This lecture, we go
through the recipe.
And then later on we'll see
how we actually apply this.
So let's look at this recipe.
So the recipe has
a number of steps.
And the key is to just
follow those steps in order
to get to the desired result.
The first step is to label
incoming and outgoing
four-momenta of particles.
We label them with
p1, p2, and up to pn.
We also want to label
all internal momenta.
So we have an
internal line, then we
want to label this internal
momenta with q1, q2, and so on.
We want to add
arrows to each line
to keep track of what is a
positive direction, as we
discussed before, particles
might travel backwards in time.
Those are typically
antiparticles.
And for those we, have to
make sure that we correctly
account for the momenta.
For each vertex,
we have a factor.
We write this factor
minus ig, where
g is the coupling constant.
So this is a measure
of the strength
of the interaction involved.
Then we have a propagator.
So for each internal
line, the internal lines
are also called propagator.
We write down a factor, i
over qj squared minus mj
squared t squared.
Note that qj
squared doesn't have
to be mj squared c squared,
meaning that the parity can
be off shell, off mass shell.
You also see that there is a
complication in the integral
when you actually have those
vectors being the same.
You want to make sure that
energy and momentum is
conserved.
So for each vertex, you
write down a delta function
with the conditions.
This is for this three vertex
where momentum of the first one
plus the second plus
the third is equal to 0.
Only then the value of
the delta function is 1.
Remember, there's a
minus sign somewhere,
most likely here
for this k1 value.
Then you want to integrate
overall internal momenta.
So for each internal
line, we write a factor--
1 over 2 pi to the fourth power.
d4 is on your momenta.
And then, this all will
result in a delta function,
which you just eliminate.
And you do that
by multiplying it.
You erase this delta
function and you replace it
by a factor i.
So this seems like
very confusing.
Why do you add delta
functions first, and then
you erase them later?
Note in Fermi's
golden rule, we use
the squared of the amplitude.
And you also saw that the
[? phase-based ?] factors
already have this kind of
delta functions included.
So we get out of the
complications that we
don't really know what to
square of the delta function is
by erasing, by adding the
i and then keeping track
of the momentum conservation,
this conservation here when we
apply the
[? phase-based ?] factor.
And then, voila, you just
calculated a matrix element.
All right, so those
are the rules.
Now the key is to practice
how to apply them.
So what we do next is to
practice using this toy
experiment in how to
calculate the matrix element,
the [? phase ?] base, and the z
decay rates and cross sections.
And then as a following step, we
will see how this all unfolds.
Then we have a real
series, like QED,
like the weak interaction
and the strong interaction.